vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos de cómo
simplificar expresiones trigonométricas
usando lo que ya hemos aprendido la
identidad trigonométricas pitagórica así
que por ejemplo si yo quiero simplificar
un poco uno menos seno cuadrado de theta
esto todo esto a su vez por el coseno
coseno cuadrado de theta como lo puedo
simplificar como puedo llevar a esto
algo un poco más elegante bueno pues
para eso voy a utilizar que ya sé que el
coseno cuadrado de un ángulo más el seno
cuadrado de un ángulo esto es
exactamente igual que uno o bueno esto
también lo podemos ver de la siguiente
manera si yo esté aquí despejó al coseno
o al seno y se me ocurre despejar al
jose no me quedaría que el coche no
cuadrado de un ángulo esto es
exactamente lo mismo que uno
y este es seno cuadrado lo voy a pasar
del otro lado restando o dicho otra
manera voy a restar de ambos lados de la
ecuación seno cuadrado de teta menos
seno cuadrado de teta y una vez que ya
tenemos esta fabulosa identidad
trigonométricas pitagórica entonces
vamos a utilizarla para sustituir la
aquí ahora yo podría sustituir el coste
no cuadrado de teta por uno menos el
seno cuadrado de teta pero aquí tengo
uno menos el seno cuadrado de teta creo
que es mucho más fácil en lugar de esto
de aquí reemplazarlo por coseno cuadrado
de teta entonces esto de aquí esto de
aquí es coseno cuadrado de teta
me va a quedar coseno cuadrado de teta
que a su vez multiplica a este de aquí a
posee no coseno cuadrado de teta y bueno
cuantos esto esto es exactamente lo
mismo que coseno cuadrado por coseno
cuadrado o coseno por coseno por coseno
por coseno lo cual es lo mismo que
coseno cuarto de teta coseno cuarto
y ya está tengo una expresión mucho más
elegante y mucho más accesible que esta
expresión con la que iniciemos así que
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo se me ocurre
tomarme el seno el seno cuadrado de teta
ya esto dividirlo entre uno menos el
seno cuadrado de teta y otra vez
utilicemos esta regla que tengo aquí yo
sé que uno menos el seno cuadrado de
teta es el co seno cuadrado de teta
entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí esto me va
a quedar como el seno el seno cuadrado
de teta esto dividido entre uno menos el
seno cuadrado que dijimos que es el
coseno cuadrado de teta y bueno lo estoy
poniendo así porque quiero que te des
cuenta de algo muy bonito aquí tengo
seno cuadrado detectan entre coseno
cuadrado de teta estás de acuerdo que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que ponerse
no detectan entre
se detecta entre coseno de teta todo
esto elevado al cuadrado
todo esto elevado al cuadrado si yo me
tomo el cuadrado de esta fracción
tendría el seno cuadrado dt está entre
el coste al cuadrado de teta ahora bien
date cuenta que ese no detecta entre
cocina beteta están gente de teta por lo
tanto esto se puede simplificar a
tangente dt tan elevado al cuadrado o
qué feo paréntesis elevado al cuadrado o
dicho de otra manera tangente cuadrada
de teta y ya está se ve mucho mejor
tangente cuadrada de teta es la
expresión mucho más elegante y mucho más
sencilla de comprender que ese no
cuadrado dt está entre 1 - seno cuadrado
y todo esto gracias a esta identidad
pitagórica así que vamos a hacer un
último ejemplo se me ocurre ahora
tomarme esta expresión de aquí coseno
coseno cuadrado detentan ya esto le voy
a sumar 1
y a esto le voy a sumar am se me ocurre
el seno el seno cuadrado de teta que me
va a dar esto y bueno lo puse con
colores para que se vea de una manera
muy sencilla que aquí tenemos el coche
no cuadrado de un ángulo más el seno
cuadrado del mismo ángulo por lo tanto
esto es exactamente lo mismo estos dos
se reducen a uno es juegos también
entidad trigonométricas pitagórica la
principal que tengo aquí ya esto le voy
a sumar le voy a sumar este otro uno de
color salmón uno de color salmón y bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 112 es
decir que con seno cuadrado de teta más
uno más en la cuadra beteta es simple y
sencillamente 2 el 2 que siempre
conocemos